In about 24 hours, I'm gonna have 9,
10 year olds sleeping over in my house for my daughter's birthday.
They're doing, like a spa slumber party situation.
This is the state of my living room right now.
Anyone who tells you balloon garlands are easy is lying to you.
Um, this is where we're at.
I've been working on the balloon Garland for at least
an hour and a half. It's not up yet.
Stay tuned for all the decor she's doing Wednesday.
Adam themed, cause she's, like,
so freaking cool.
And I'm pretty much killing myself trying to make this, like,
the coolest birthday ever
cause it's 10. It's double digits.
It's gotta be big. I might be more excited than she is.